und die kanzlerin macht ja auch
sozusagen druck vor dem treffen morgen
sie warnen davor dass die verdoppelung
also viermal die verdoppelung geht der
fallzahlen zu einem ende des systems für
das krankenhaus des versorgungssystems
und dann altmaier der
wirtschaftsminister er spricht von
20.000 infizierten pro tag ende der
woche schon also noch mal mehr als die
kanzlerin ja für weihnachten angekündigt
hat das sind alles aussagen und zahlen
die ja zumindest einen verunsichern
sollte uns denn diese 20.000
neuinfizierten pro tag tatsächlich
verunsichern oder ist das eine zahl wie
sie halt passiert in einer pandemie aber
bricht dadurch das system zusammen es
ist sehr wichtig sich nicht nur an der
zahl selbst aufzuhalten
das haben wir jetzt in den sechs sieben
monaten wirklich zu genüge getan es ist
wichtig hinter die zahl zu schauen und
vor allem darauf zu achten wer sich denn
ansteckt und zwar ist es sehr wichtig
dass sich ältere menschen nicht
infizieren also menschen die 50 60 70
denn das ist die risikogruppe das ist
sehr einfach zu sagen je mehr ältere
menschen sich ein ansteckend sich mit
dem virus infizieren desto mehr schwere
fälle wird es geben desto voller werden
die krankenhäuser und die intensivbetten
und das war die warnung der
bundeskanzlerin wenn sich die zahl der
belegten intensivbetten noch vier mal
verdoppelt dann ist die kapazitätsgrenze
erreicht deswegen jahr auf der einen
seite gilt es jetzt die zahlen insgesamt
zu senken auf der anderen seite gilt es
aber auch gerade die älteren bürger zu
schützen wenn man sich mal anschaut was
im frühjahr geschehen ist da war der
anteil älterer bürger die sich
angesteckt haben also eben die über 70
80 über 90 sogar über hundertjährigen da
war der anteil sehr hoch der ist noch
sehr niedrig in den vergangenen wochen
waren das 2 3 4 prozent die über 80
waren an den gesamten infektionen
ja aber auch das kann natürlich
gefährlich sein wenn die zahlen ins
zwar steigen aber dennoch es gilt zu
vermeiden dass es schwere fälle gibt und
das heißt man muss ältere person
schützen denn das sind die schweren
fälle die unsere krankenhäuser auch
irgendwann an den rande des kollapses
bringen könnten mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schaue ich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren